(energetic tropical music)
- Plants are the foundation for all life.
Understanding plant diversity is critical
to our continued survival.
The goal of the World Flora
Online is to accumulate
in one place, on a website, a
description and illustrations
of every known plant species.
We are about five years into the process.
We are accumulating new specimens.
We're digitizing them, and
all of that information feeds
in ultimately to the World Flora Online.
(suspenseful music)
The main way that our specimens come to us
is that they are collected in the field.
When they're here, they are
mounted onto stiff paper.
The information about
the plant is transcribed
onto a little label that
goes along with the specimen.
A good mounter can do
about 50 specimens per day.
Once the specimens are
mounted, we photograph them.
Then, that information goes
online pretty much immediately.
The project began in 2010,
and it is meant to be completed by 2020.
We've photographed about 2.6
million of our specimens.
Worldwide, it must be on the
order of 10 or 15 million.
(soft acoustic music)
Plants are endlessly fascinating,
and we have to know what
they are and how they differ
from one another in order to understand
what kind of measures need
to be taken to protect them.